one major crisis after another has
shaken Europe to its core
accused of always doing too little too
late or kicking the can down the road
parliament has already laid out
ambitious plans for the future of Europe
and now it's Commission President
jean-claude yonkers turn armed with five
scenarios on how the Union can move
forward post brexit future long about us
has dimension from a rope Everton
survived and found fun Dame that I woke
up beaten with license of computer
scientist to Martin I hope our new ideas
ranged from business as usual to
creating a union pulling EU states much
closer together the urgency of having a
clear way forward was in everyone's
minds we have done many things wrong
before arriving to this point brexit is
not the cause
brexit is the last consequence and we
must be sure it remains the last
consequence some expected more
leadership from the Commission you are
presenting us with a pre reflection
paper and the scenarios instead of a
clear plan to fortify our house to
weather this storm quantities idiot who
are finally behind you to decide to boot
Nadezhda gunshots as what works too
tight as he teases Parliament Fenella
politic this one thing whose fab shield
and that's one of the challenges Europe
has yet to fully overcome
you